okay it's time to introduce you to a new
friend Eli the Iceman Eli the Iceman is
a friend of every electrical engineer
and what we've been talking about is AC
analysis and in AC analysis we limit
ourselves to one type of signal and
that's a sinusoidal story we like is
called cosine we say cosine of Omega T
plus V Omega represents the the Radian
frequency of the cosine here it's shown
in blue that Radian frequency is Omega
and fee is the phase delay or the phase
shift and if we look here we see this
isn't really a cosine wave because the
peak is a little before zero time equals
zero so this distance right here is the
lead the phase lead and that's fee so
when fee is a positive number this whole
cosine wave is shifted a little bit to
the left that's what we mean by phase
shift so when these kind of signals are
input into our favorite components we're
going to get a relationship between the
voltage and the current in those
components and this related by the
impedance we've defined the idea of
impedance as the ratio of voltage to
current we gave that the symbol Z now in
this video instead of using V as my
variable for voltage I'm going to use a
different letter I'm going to use e e is
short for EMF or electro-motive force
and it's really commonly used almost as
often as as V for representing voltage
and I'll show you why I want to use E in
a little bit
and another way I can write this just as
easily e equals Z times I and this looks
a lot like Ohm's law and what we're
going to find out here is we can apply
this in addition to applying it to
resistors we can apply it to capacitors
and inductors so first off we're going
to look at our friend the inductor and
we're going to look at the equation e
equals Z I for an inductor I'm going to
assign I to be a sinusoidal to some
magnitude we'll call it I naught cosine
Omega T plus V so I'm going to say my
current is a cosine wave of this
magnitude with this phase delay and
that's shown in blue here so this here
is I and now let's write e in terms of
this I here so I can write e equals e
now what is Z for an inductor the
impedance of an inductor is J Omega L
and what is I I is sitting right here
now I'm going to represent I like this
I'm going to represent I as a phasor or
a phasor representation and we said that
that can be represented as I the
magnitude of the current indicated at
the angle of fee so these are equivalent
representations of I this is the time
domain representation and this is the
phasor representation now what we have
out here in front of I is a scaling
factor there's this complex J that will
take care of in a second and there's
Omega L so Omega is the frequency and L
is the size of the inductor now for the
purposes of this video when I plot out
the voltage over here in orange I'm
going to we're going to assume that the
scaling factor Omega L is one just so
that we can focus on the timing
relations
ships between the current and the
voltage when we talked about complex
numbers multiplying by J multiplying
something by J represents a rotation of
plus 90 degrees and so I can write this
as e equals let's put the let's put the
scaling factor out there and we'll have
I naught which is the original magnitude
of the current and feet it's changed
your fee changes fee becomes fee and
this multiplication by J here
corresponds to adding 90 degrees to feed
so multiplying by J corresponds to a 90
degree phase shift and if I draw here
this is now e and the phase shift we
decided this distance right here this
distance right here is fie and this
distance right here is a phase lead of
90 degrees
and you'll notice I off the peaks of
these these waveforms because that's the
easiest place to see the lead so when I
move to the left that corresponds to a
lead of plus 90 degrees so in an
inductor in an inductor in an inductor
we say that e leads I
by 90 degrees
all right
now let's do it for our capacitor and
we'll do the same kind of thing here for
a capacitor
we'll assign the same current will say I
equals some current I knot times cosine
of Omega T plus fee and now let's work
out the voltage across the capacitor so
the voltage across the capacitor e is
the same thing we have here e equals e I
or I can write e in the capacitor equals
Z now what is impedance of a capacitor
it's 1 over J Omega C that's Z and I we
represent the same way as we did before
I knot at an angle of fee
so now let's carefully do this this
multiplication e equals 1 over J times 1
over Omega C times I naught and an angle
of V so here's this 1 over J term now I
can rewrite 1 over J as minus J now
we're multiplying something by minus J
and multiplying by minus J corresponds
to a rotation of minus 90 degrees so I
can write e one more time like this e
equals 1 over Omega C there's the scale
factor here's the original current
magnitude and I get the angle of fee
this time minus 90 degrees
so this minus sign here corresponds to a
lag a phase lag so here's our original
current here let me label that here's I
and now we have our voltage e looks like
this here's E and what we see let me go
out here and measure it here here we
have a phase lag we're pointing to the
right of 90 degrees and that we call a
lag we can summarize that we can say in
a capacitor we say e lags I and an
equivalent way to say this is we could
say that I leads e I leads voltage
so I can actually put boxes around these
two results here and here now there's a
lot of sign flipping going on here and
there's actually an easy way to remember
this and I want to introduce you to
someone who can help you remember this
and his name is Eli the Iceman
so what can Li tell us Eli tells us that
in an inductor and L voltage leads
current and over here in a capacitor C
current leads voltage that's the message
from Eli the Iceman he helps us remember
the order that voltage and current
change in inductors and capacitors he's
going to be your friend for a long time